[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend dass
man den Hahn aufdreht und Wasser
rauskommt in beliebigen Mengen eine
Selbstverständlichkeit aber so
selbstverständlich ist das eben nicht
was er Mangel ist längst auch ein Thema
in Deutschland und ist auch eines der
Hauptthemen auf dem deutschen Bauerntag
der heute in Münster begonnen hat
Trinkwasser für den privaten Verbrauch
wird gemäß der nationalen
wasserstrategie immer Vorrang haben aber
in manchen Kommunen gibt es ja jetzt
schon Appelle dass man seinen privaten
Garten erst abends wässern oder aufs
Auto waschen verzichtet für die
Landwirtschaft ist die Lage weit ernster
wie Christian Kirsch berichtet
Unterfranken zum Beispiel der Landstrich
am Main eher eine trockene Gegend aber
die Zeiten werden noch härter hier oben
im Weinberg setzt Winzer Thomas Schwab
inzwischen auf Bewässerung seiner
Rebstöcke tröpfchenweise Wasser Technik
aus Israel was sonst die Wüste begrünt
hilft jetzt dem Wein in Deutschland
warum
wir bewässern den Weinberg weil wir die
Erfahrung gemacht haben dass es den
jungen Reben gut tut wenn wir bis zum
Alter von etwa zehn Jahren diese
Rebstöcke bewässern später ist es dann
nicht mehr nötig weil dann die Wurzeln
tief genug sind und der Weinberg auf so
genug Wasser bekommt
seit Jahrhunderten bauen Sie hier Wein
an Bewässerung war nie von Nöten die
Dinge ändern sich in Zeiten des
Klimawandels an der Universität Würzburg
belegen langjährige Messreihen es fehlt
der Regen schon gut die Menge eines
ganzen Jahres das wird so bleiben die
neue deutsche wasserwirklichkeit wir
sind eigentlich in den mittleren Breiten
in einer Klimazone die dadurch
gekennzeichnet ist dass wir eine sehr
regelmäßige Verteilung der Niederschläge
haben und das ändert sich im Zuge des
Klimawandels das Sagen im Prinzip alle
Klimamodelle für Mittel Europa und
spende speziell auch für die Mitte
Deutschlands voraus
und was konkret bedeutet das ja es ist
bedeutet dass wir genau dann wenn wir
viel Wasser brauchen nämlich in der
wärmeren Jahreszeit dieses Wasser aus
den Niederschlag früher oder später
einfach nicht mehr zur Verfügung steht
die Folge Dürre trockene Gärten trockene
Felder aus Flüssen werden Rinnsale und
wenn es regnet dann meistens Sturz
Becken die trockenen harten Böden können
die Wassermassen nicht aufnehmen
am trockenen Ufer der sommerlichen Elbe
steht Uwe Ritzer Journalist er sieht
Deutschland vor dem Wassernotstand
fordert Wasser zu sparen vor allem von
der Industrie und auch in der
Landwirtschaft
Deutschland hat seit dem Jahr 2000 etwa
20 Prozent seiner Wasservorräte verloren
das ist etwa einmal die Menge des
Bodensees damit gehört Deutschland zu
den Ländern mit dem höchsten
Wasserverlust vergleichbare Länder wenn
das so weitergeht steuern wir in
Deutschland unweigerlich auf einen
Wassernotstand zu und wir müssen jetzt
etwas tun damit in 5 in 10 in 15 Jahren
das Problem nicht so Gewalt auf uns
zukommt das ist richtig unangenehm wird
was also tun wenn Trinkwasser aus dem
Hahn selbstverständlich bleiben soll
Fachleute fordern einen Umbau der
Industrielandschaft es gibt die
Möglichkeit die natürliche
schwammwirkung der Landschaft zu
verbessern indem wir Terrassierungen
anlegen indem wir wieder auffassen
damit das Wasser das fällt vor allen
Dingen im Winter nicht mehr so schnell
über die Vorfluter das heißt die
flussysteme aus der Landschaft rauskommt
um den Grundwasserhaushalt in
Deutschland wieder auszugleichen rechnen
Fachleute müsste es derzeit ein halbes
Jahr durchgehen regnen ausgeschlossen
Winter Thomas Schwab bewässert daher im
Trockenen juni weiter seinen Weinberg
in Franken
darüber wollen wir mit Professor
Dietrich Borchert sprechen er ist
hydrobiologe ich sag mal vereinfacht
wasserexperte und leitet am
Helmholtz-Zentrum den Themenbereich
Wasser Ressourcen und Umwelt guten Abend
Herr Professor Borchert guten Abend
russlandke wenn man das als ich ansieht
also auch Weinbauern fangen jetzt an zu
bewässern was es früher nicht gab dann
stellt sich natürlich die Frage wenn die
Wasservorräte knapper werden wo kommt
das Wasser dafür denn dann her
das Wasser für Bewässerung in der
Landwirtschaft kann im Grunde genommen
aus zwei Quellen kommen entweder aus
Oberflächengewässern oder aus
Grundwasser wenn bewässert werden muss
und ähm die Frage ist dann immer eine
regionale Frage nämlich sind
Wasservorräte vorhanden die man
nachhaltig nutzen kann die auch
zukünftig noch in entsprechenden Mengen
vorhanden sind oder nicht und die zweite
Frage wird immer sein gibt es noch
andere Nutzungen die auf dieselbe Wasser
Ressource zugreifen sind da mehr Winzer
sind da vielleicht auch
Trinkwasserversorger sind da vielleicht
aber auch Feuchtgebiete die ihr Wasser
brauchen und so werden wir in Zukunft
mit uns auf Ehren Nutzungskonkurrenzen
einstellen müssen und die werden wir zu
lösen haben davon aus dass Bewässerung
das Thema Bewässerung in der
Landwirtschaft zu nehmen wird
davon gehe ich fest aus im Moment spielt
Bewässerung in Deutschland bezogen auf
die landwirtschaftliche Nutzfläche
tatsächlich nur eine sehr untergeordnete
Rolle es sind vielleicht zweieinhalb
Prozent der gesamten
landwirtschaftlichen Nutzfläche auch
dann vor allen Dingen nur in Bezug im
Moment auf einzelne Sonderkulturen zu
denen auch weinen oder Obstbau gehört
oder vielleicht Kartoffelanbau in Teilen
Niedersachsens aber es ist fest davon
auszugehen dass der bewässerungsbedarf
auch andere Regionen aber auch andere
Anbaumethoden in Zukunft betreffen wird
und schon mittelfristig sehr viel größer
sein wird dann müsste man aber ja ein
anderer Stelle wenn sie sagen es gibt
dann da auch eine Konkurrenz zum
wassereinsparen größeren Umfang
zunächst mal ist der Ausgangspunkt an
dem zu arbeiten ist wirklich die
Inventare zu verbessern und mit damit
meine ich dass einerseits bekannt sein
muss wie viel Wasser ist denn regional
vorhanden und zwar geht es um die
gesamten Wasserkreislauf also wie viel
Niederschlag wie viel Bodenfeuchte wie
viel Grundwasser aber ist da vielleicht
auch eine Talsperre ist dort ein großes
Oberflächengewässer wie der Bodensee in
der Nähe
also die
Angebotsseite und das zweite ist wir
brauchen bessere Inventare darüber wer
eigentlich Wasser nutzt nutzen darf
nutzt und vor allen Dingen in welcher
Menge er ist auch tut weil daraus erst
die Bilanz werden kann aufgrund dessen
Grundlage man beurteilen auf deren
Grundlage man beurteilen kann wird denn
eine wasserrisshaus übernutzt oder nicht
aber man weiß dann welche Daten
vorliegen also wer was nutzt aber
dadurch wird der Grundwasserspiegel ja
auch nicht besser wenn der jetzt schon
so abgesunken ist was wäre denn da die
wichtigste Maßnahme die wichtigste
Maßnahme ist tatsächlich das Grundwasser
zu beobachten die Trends zu beobachten
zu bestimmen wie auch langfrist
Entwicklung sind weil wir haben es immer
mit zwei Aspekten dieser Veränderung
dieses neuen normals zu tun wir müssen
krisenhafte Situationen bewältigen wie
wir sie jetzt gerade haben eine
mehrjährige Dürre die jedes Jahr auch
sich ein Stück weit aufschaukelt genauso
wie wir jetzt Entscheidungen brauchen
und da reden wir über
Trinkwasserversorgung wir reden da über
Infrastrukturen die sich nur in
Jahrzehnten anpassen lassen das ist
nicht von einem Jahr auf das nächste
gemacht und deswegen müssen wir uns auch
mit Klima Szenarien auseinandersetzen
die uns sagen wie sieht denn die
Situation vielleicht im Jahr 2015/2016
aus wenn sie von Trinkwasserversorgung
sprechen die hat ja nach wie vor immer
vor aber im europäischen Ausland wo es
zum Teil ja schon sehr viel heftiger
zugeht als in Deutschland nicht in
Italien Frankreich da gibt's ja schon
Ortschaften wo im Sommer dann ist gar
kein Trinkwasser Naht also das kam
jedenfalls nicht mehr aus dem Harn
sondern musste mit
Containern herangebracht werden sind
solche Szenarien in einzelnen Regionen
Deutschlands auch denkbar
es hat sie ja vereinzelt in extremen
Situationen tatsächlich auch schon
gegeben aber nur wirklich sehr
vereinzelt ich würde
erwarten dass wenn man dieses
Wassermanagement auf diese extreme wie
gerade gesagt wirklich ausrichtet wenn
es vor allen Dingen auch im Krisenfall
dann zu zunächst einmal abgestuften
Handeln geht also sprich zunächst die
Bevölkerung sensibilisieren die
nutzersensibilisieren und dann erstmal
mit Reduktionen arbeiten und dann das
haben wir jetzt aber auch schon wird es
auch immer wieder zu Wasser
nutzungsverboten kommen oder das Wasser
Nutzungseinschränkungen wie zum Beispiel
im Moment in einzelnen Landkreisen in
Deutschland die Entnahme von Wasser aus
Oberflächen Gewässern z.B für die
landwirtschaftliche Bewässerung aber
auch für andere Zwecke und auf solche
Beschränkungen werden wir uns in Zukunft
einstellen müssen
danke für das Gespräch in die Expertise
ich danke Ihnen
in Südfrankreich gibt es inzwischen
sogar wieder Prozessionen bei denen um
Regen gebetet wird nur dass die anders
als früher nicht am Ende eines langen
Sommers stattfinden sondern bereits im
Frühjahr und damit kommen wir zu unserem
nächsten Thema in der katholischen
Kirche müsste man in diesen Tagen vor
allem darum beten dass der rapide
Mitgliederschwund aufhört
Negativschlagzeilen wie gestern als wir
im Kölner Kardinal Woelke die
Staatsanwaltschaft vor der Tür stand
dürften da allerdings wenig hilfreich
sein heute wurden die Austrittszahlen
von 2022 veröffentlicht die für die
katholische Kirche noch dramatischer
sind als sie befürchtet mehr als eine
halbe Million so viele wie noch nie
traten aus das hat auch finanzielle
Folgen wie ein Stern Bericht
wenn bei Familie Roma die Hausaufgaben
und damit das Thema Schule auf den Tisch
kommen hat das ganz viel zu tun mit der
Kirchenkrise mit Austritten und mit
massiver Kritik Susan Romas jüngster
Sohn Leo geht auf die Martinusschule
Gonsenheim in Mainz lange eine Schule
des Bistums doch das Bistum muss seit
Jahren sparen auch wegen der
austrittswellen und entzog der Schule
das Geld das haben wir über die Presse
erfahren mit uns Eltern oder hat da
keiner gesprochen ich war damals der
schulelternbeiratsvorsitzenden von der
Martinusschule Mainz Gonsenheim und habe
das genauso durch die Presse erfahren
wie alle anderen auch die Eltern waren
entsetzt nahmen das Problem selbst in
die Hand suchten neue Träger und konnten
die Schule retten die Folge teuer ein
schulbeitrag wurde fällig bis zu 200 €
pro Kind das Verhalten der katholischen
Kirche für viele ein Grund auszutreten
ja also ich kenne Eltern mehrere Eltern
und wir sind da auch im Austausch das
ist tatsächlich so dass die Menschen
sagen oder die Eltern sagen okay wenn
ich jetzt einen Elternbeitrag bezahlen
muss für die Schule dann trete ich aber
aus aus der Kirche auch im Zusammenhang
mit dem Umgang mit den Missbrauchsfällen
und so weiter wo Sie vielleicht schon
gehadert haben ist das jetzt der Punkt
wo sie sagen okay dann trete ich aus der
Kirche aus
insgesamt weit mehr als eine halbe
Million Menschen sind 2022
deutschlandweit ausgetreten so viele wie
noch nie noch viel mehr als im
vorherigen Rekordjahr 2021 verheerende
zahlen das Vertrauen in die katholische
Kirche singt schnell immer weiter ich
glaube das eine ist dieses fehlende
Vertrauen dass diese Institution
wirklich den Turnaround schafft und
Reformen anpackt und das jetzt gerade
auch die Menschen die bisher sehr
engagiert waren in der katholischen
Kirche und doch immer noch die Hoffnung
gehabt haben jawoll es wird sich etwas
verändern dass die sehen es kommt keine
veränder ung es geht zu langsam und das
ist auch die dieser harte Kern die
Kirche lässt der harte Kern der jetzt
auch geht Kern Schmelze also belegt mit
frischen zahlen doch der Vorsitzende der
Deutschen Bischofskonferenz will dazu
heute kein Interview geben und schickt
seinen pressesprecher
das ist heute ein bitterer Tag an dem
auch nichts schöngerät werden muss diese
gigantischen Austrittszahlen die uns
Schmerzen als Kirchen Deutschland zeigen
dass wir tiefen
glaubwürdigkeiten Vertrauenskrise sind
wir müssen jetzt alle Anstrengungen
ansetzen um aus dieser Krise irgendwie
herauszukommen
irgendwie herauskommen aus einer Lage in
der sich die Menschen zu
Hunderttausenden von der katholischen
Kirche in Deutschland abwenden
und jetzt geht es bei dir in den
Nachrichten weiter eins es gibt neues
zum Tarifkonflikt bei der Bahn
hat der Eisenbahn und
Verkehrsgewerkschaft EVG in dem
festgefahrenen Tarifkonflikt eine
Schlichtung vorgeschlagen das gab der
Konzern heute bekannt und erklärte damit
solle der Tarif Konflikt ohne weitere
Streiks in der Ferienzeit beigelegt
werden zuvor war bekannt geworden dass
die EVG offenbar morgen über weitere
waren Streits entscheiden will zu einer
Schlichtung hieß es von der Gewerkschaft
dann man wäre den Vorschlag prüfen
nach dem tödlichen Schuss eines
Polizisten auf einen 17-Jährigen im
Pariser vorordner ter hat sich
Frankreichs Präsident macron bestürzt
geäußert er nannte den Vorfall
unentschuldbar bei einer
Verkehrskontrolle hatte der Polizist den
17-Jährigen aus nächster Nähe
angeschossen und tödlich verletzt in
namter und anderen Pariser vorstellten
war es daraufhin zu wütenden Protesten
gekommen die Polizei wurde mit
Feuerwerkskörpern angegriffen und setzte
Tränengas ein
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
ist zu einem Antrittsbesuch nach
Washington gereist empfangen wurde er
von seinem Amtskollegen Leute Austin mit
dem er die Lage in der Ukraine erörtern
wird die Reise dient auch der
Vorbereitung des kommenden NATO-Gipfels
in Litauen
doch in der Ukraine selbst ging es heute
erneut um die nato-perspektive des
Landes Präsident selenski sprach in Kiew
mit den Präsidenten von Polen und
litauenseder über den im Juli
anstehenden NATO-Gipfel es ging auch um
die weitere Unterstützung der Ukraine
und die Lage an der Front
einige Kilometer von der Front entfernt
liegt die ukrainische Stadt grammatos
durch einen russischen Raketenangriff
sind dort nach ukrainischen Angaben
mindestens zehn Menschen getötet worden
bei dem Angriff gestern Abend wurden im
Stadtzentrum ein Restaurant sowie
Wohnungen und Geschäfte getroffen
das Schlimmste sind die verlorenen leben
aber auch die materielle Zerstörung in
der Ukraine ist unfassbar
ganze Ortschaften dem Erdboden
gleichgemacht große landwirtschaftliche
Flächen vermiet Kulturgüter geraubt und
zerstört zuletzt noch die ökologische
Katastrophe infolge des zerbrochenen
Staudamms
mit Ziffern lässt sich das alles kauen
die Weltbank stellte kürzlich rund 400
Milliarden als Finanzbedarf von den Raum
die Europäer diskutieren aktuell darüber
inwieweit man eingefrorene russische
Vermögen heranziehen könnte das wird
wohl auch Thema beim EU-Gipfel am
Donnerstag sein ultra berichtet
wer zahlt für den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine für die gezielte Zerstörung der
Infrastruktur für das Leid der russische
Präsident Putin die Eliten mit ihren
vielen Milliarden das russische Volk
oder Europas Steuerzahler
390 Milliarden für den Wiederaufbau für
die Ukraine werden gebraucht so
Schätzungen der Weltbank die
EU-Kommission gibt eine eindeutige
Antwort
gezogen werden
zur Rechenschaft ziehen in einer
perfekten Welt kann das auch so aussehen
im Bremerhaven hat die EU die Yacht von
einem russischen Oligarchen eingezogen
insgesamt hat die EU russisches Vermögen
im Wert von 350 Milliarden Euro
eingeführt in Europa wollen viele dass
das putinsystem für den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine zahlt
warum sollten denn unsere Steuerzahler
für den Wiederaufbau bezahlen sie haben
die Ukraine nicht zerstört wir müssen
eine Lösung in Europa finden die uns
rechtlich erlaubt dass eingefrorene
russische Vermögen zu verwenden
das wird nicht einfach Putin der Mann
der brutal das Völkerrecht gebrochen hat
wird aber vom Völkerrecht geschützt
Staaten können nicht einfach andere
Staaten und deren Bürger enteignen auch
die Zinsen die das eingefrorene
russische Vermögen bringen kann Europa
wohl nur schwer für den Wiederaufbau
verwenden der direkte Zugriff ist kaum
möglich wir beschlagnahmen zwar aber der
endgültige Entzug ist ein
völkerrechtliche Grenzen und das gilt
ebenso für die Verwertung dieses
Vermögens man könnte es ja anlegen und
daraus ganz ins Gewinne Wirtschaften
auch das wird vom eigentums-
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
geht noch einen anderen Weg sie will der
Ukraine bis 2027 weitere 50 Milliarden
Euro zur Verfügung stellen die
Diskussion mit den Regierungschefs kommt
das Geld aus vorhandenen EU-Töpfen oder
bekommt die Ukraine zusätzliches Geld
von den EU-Staaten das wäre mal richtig
dass wir die Ukraine unterstützen und
müssen auch finanziell aber das wird
nicht einfach nur durch mehr Geld aus
dem Mitgliedstaaten finanziert werden
können da muss frau von allein so mutig
sein auch im EU-Haushalt Umschichtung
vorzunehmen denn da ist in manchen
Bereichen auch noch genug Geld vorhanden
wer zahlt für die Zerstörung Europa
sucht nach einem gerechten weg damit
Putin nicht davonkommt
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit anderen
Nachrichten den Euro soll es künftig
nicht mehr nur in Münzen und Scheinen
geben sondern auch digital ein
entsprechender Gesetzesvorschlag kommt
von der EU-Kommission Frank Bethmann wie
soll das konkret aussehen mit dem
digitalen Euro ja die Banken könnten den
digitalen Euro wie Bargeld von den
Notenbanken beziehen Verbraucher würden
ihnen in einer digitalen Geldbörse einer
sogenannten Wallet gutgeschrieben
bekommen das Smartphone ist dann
praktisch das Portemonnaie Händler wären
verpflichtet neben Scheinen und Münzen
auch diese Variante als offizielles
Zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren
gleichzeitig gesagt die EU der digitale
Euro sollen keinesfalls das Bargeld
ersetzen er solle ist nur ergänzen vor
allem weil wir in einer Zeit leben in
der immer mehr Prozesse vor allem in der
Wirtschaft digital ablaufen würden
bräuchte es eben auch diese neue Form
einer offiziellen Währung mit der
allerdings frühestens 2026 zu rechnen
ist
und nun gibt es ja schon digitale
bezahlt Angebote was wäre der Vorteil
wenn noch ein digitaler Euro kommt ja
das Hauptargument ganz sicher mit einem
digitalen Euro bequemer Europa ein
Angebot für digitale Zahlungen als
Alternative zu Zahlungsdienstleistern
aus den USA wie beispielsweise VISA
Mastercard oder Paypal sie dominieren
den Markt hier zu Lande zusätzlich will
der digitale Euro bei den Bürgern damit
punkten dass er sicher ist schließlich
steht hinter dieser Bezahlvariante die
Europäische Zentralbank ob das alles
allerdings reicht die Bürger zu
überzeugen die Skepsis besonders unter
den Bargeld verliebten deutschen ist
aktuell sehr groß Frank Wittmann vielen
Dank
eine Studie der Universität Leipzig hat
rechtsextreme Einstellungen und die
Zufriedenheit mit der Demokratie in den
ostdeutschen Bundesländern untersucht
die Auswertung der repräsentativen
Befragung von rund 3.500 Personen zeige
hohe Zustimmungswerte zur rechtsextremen
Aussagen so die Autoren mit der
Demokratie als Idee könnte sich zwar
eine deutliche Mehrheit identifizieren
noch nicht mal ein Viertel der Befragten
meine Einfluss auf die Regierung zu
haben und mehr zu der Studie und ein
Gespräch mit einem Landrat aus Thüringen
später im heute journal Update
das Bundesverfassungsgericht verhandelt
seit heute darüber ob in einem
Abiturzeugnis ein Vermerk wegen
Legasthenie stehen darf drei ehemalige
Abiturienten aus Bayern haben in
Karlsruhe Verfassungsbeschwerde
eingelegt sie sehen in einem solchen
Vermerk eine berufliche Einschränkung
das bayerische Kultusministerium
verweist dagegen auf
Chancengerechtigkeit und Transparenz
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 5 18 28 30 34 37 Superzahl 1
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
Fußballnationalspieler Kai havertz
bislang unter Vertrag beim Premier
League Club FC Chelsea Wechsel zum
Stadtrivalen FC Eisenach der 24-Jährige
erhält beim englischen Vizemeister einen
langfristigen Vertrag wie der Londoner
Club mitteilte wie hoch die Ablösesumme
ist wurde nicht bekannt gegeben
die deutsche U21
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft ist bei der
EM in Georgien und Rumänien in der
Gruppenphase gescheitert im letzten
Spiel heute gab es eine 0 zu 2
Niederlage gegen England
das war brutal die deutschen vorgeführt
verunsichert ausgeschieden kein einziger
Sieg in der Vorrunde gegen England
komplett unterlegen die Young Lions von
Beginn an fast zu schnell zu wach dass
es zu einfach in der vierten Minute
schon das 1:0 durch Cameron Archer die
DFB-Elf von Trainer Antonio di salvo
erspielt kaum Chancen wie diese zum
Ausgleich die deutschen irgendwie müde
und direkt im Anschluss der englische
Keeper hellwach nutzt die Resignation
und schickt HWL jetzt der macht allein
2:0 das ist bitter in der zweiten Hälfte
haben die Deutschen schon aufgegeben
wenige Angriffe in der 90 Minute noch
mal Jessica lang kam aber keine Chance
England gewinnt 2:0 und Titelverteidiger
deutschland ist mit nur einem Punkt aus
drei Spielen als Tabellenletzter
ausgeschieden und damit auch nicht für
die Olympischen Spiele qualifiziert
der Hut ist immer noch der gleiche der
Mann der ihn trägt allerdings ein
bisschen
älter geworden mit 80 Jahren noch einen
Actionfilm drehen das muss man auch
erstmal schaffen zum fünften und
angeblich letzten Mal ist der in der
Rolle des Indiana Jones geschlüpft rennt
und reitet um die Welt und tut all das
was in die anderen Jones halt so tut die
Filmkritiken sind durchwachsen die Fans
werden es trotzdem wohl gerne sehen und
sei es aus Nostalgie morgen ist
Kinostart
den Film schon gesehen und Harrison Ford
getroffen
diese Melodie eine Verheißung Abenteuer
Spannung Männlichkeit pur Indiana Jones
zurück in seiner parade-rolle mit 80
Jahren spielt Harrison Ford zum letzten
Mal den Archäologen und Abenteurer
Indiana Jones manchmal war es schon
anstrengend aber auch ein großer Spaß
wenn ihr jetzt im Ruhestand
für meine Patentochter mein Vater sagte
mir du hast etwas gefunden
in einem Zug während des Krieges ein Rad
das den Verlauf der Geschichte ändern
könnte
mit dem Rad des Schicksals lässt sich
Geschichte umschreiben eine gefährliche
Waffe in falschen Händen also macht sich
Pensionär in die auf die Suche noch
einmal die Welt retten und noch einmal
gegen das Böse antreten
wie immer hat er keinen Plan warum
eigentlich
weil er die Umstände in der sich hinein
begibt nicht vorhersehen kann Indiana
Jones Filme leben vom unerwarteten
seine Jagd nach dem Rad des Schicksals
beginnt die New York 1969
Aufbruchstimmung mitten im Kalten Krieg
und ihn nie also Harrison Ford gibt
alles wahrlich eine rent
ner dr Jones Wissenschaftler mit wildem
Spieltrieb das gehört zum
Schöpfungsmythos der Saga die vor über
40 Jahren mit den Jägern des verlorenen
Schatzes begann lieber Dschungel als
Hörsaal in die gegen seine
Lieblingsgegner alte Nazis die suchen
auch das Rad des Schicksals ihr Ziel
Geschichte umschreiben für ein
siegreiches Nazi-Deutschland Hitler
machte Fehler und damit werde ich sie
korrigieren
der Film beam Jones in die Hitlerzeit
zurück ein mit KI verjüngter fort seine
digitale Frischzellenkur überzeugend
[Musik]
es gibt ihn seit 40 Jahren kaum zu
leugnen also am Ende seiner Karriere
steht mir war wichtig dass es in diesem
letzten Indiana Jones auch ums Alter
geht
[Musik]
und irgendwann ist es dann auch mal
genug Indiana Jones Teil 5 in Zeiten des
superheldentums ein temporeicher
Nostalgietrip ins gute alte Hollywood
Popcorn Kino für alle
das was von uns das auslandsjournal
gleich im Anschluss beschäftigt sich
heute mit den Ereignissen in Russland
wie stark ist Putin noch und wie viel
Macht haben die privaten sollten
Armenien und um 0:30 Uhr meldet sich der
Nazan gökte mir mit unserem heute mal
Update auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das Tief bei
Island hat eine Kaltfront und die nähert
sich uns und das passiert relativ
langsam aber morgen gibt es schon erste
charre und Gewitter am Nachmittag und
davor wird ordentlich warm und feuchte
Luft herangeführt die Carl Front kommt
dann am Freitag zu uns und löst dann
teilweise heftigere Gewitter aus die
können im unwetterbereich Liegen in der
Nacht gibt es etwas Regen nach
Nordwesten hin sonst ist es trocken und
vor allem im Südosten wird es kalt mit
Temperaturen bis acht Grad und 18 Grad
ganz im Westen Deutschlands morgen am
Vormittag ist es erstmal fast überall
freundlich mit Sonnenschein nur ganz im
Westen ziehen erste Wolken teils auch
Schauer auf ja und zum Nachmittag werden
aus diesen schauen teilweise auch
Gewitter die können durchaus dann viel
Regen mitbringen Starkregen ist dann
dabei ansonsten kosten einige Wolken
Richtung Bayern viel Sonnenschein die
höchsten Temperaturen morgen bei 30 Grad
am Oberrhein generell in der Südhälfte
relativ warm zwischen 26 und 29 Grad und
nach Norden in etwas kühle vor allem an
der Nordsee bei 23 Grad am Freitag
überquerte uns die Kaltfront dann
allmählich ostwärts und dann können die
Gewitter durchaus heftiger ausfallen
Werte bei 20 bis 27 Grad und am
Wochenende ist es nicht mehr ganz so
warm und damit ein schöner Abend